-We have some drinks for you
guys just on each side
because this is actually --
this is your alcohol.
-We can do this.
We can absolutely do this.
-You guys made alcohol.
-We made it.
We drank it enough.
We decided, you know what?
Let´s make our own.
-Because it´s cheaper
if have your own.
-Might as well.
-And this is whiskey?
-Just smarter.
You know what I´m saying?
-Yeah, just smarter.
And then what´s the name of
your line of whiskey?
-Old Camp Whiskey.
-And this is the peach pecan.
-Peach pecan and we got
the American Whiskey.
-So this is peach pecan whiskey.
-Yes, sir.
-And did you feel like there was
a hole in the market
for peach pecan whiskey?
[ Laughter ]
-Kind of. Yeah. Yeah, we did
some market research.
-When I bought it, I´ve never
seen that before so...
-We´re going to give you
a little taste of
Florida and Georgia,
the peaches and the pecans.
-Oh, I did not even put it
together. There you go.
-They really make a nice combo.
-Well, cheers to the combo,
guys.
-Cheers to that. Heck, yeah.
-This is great.
It´s great.
I said it before I drank it.
-Wow!
-So I want to say it again.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
This is great, seriously.
You should buy some.
-It´s really good.
You should all buy some.
So, you guys have been the road.
You´re doing the Smooth tour.
Do you enjoy being out on
the road playing to your fans?
-We do, man.
-Absolutely.
-That´s probably
one of our favorite things,
really being on tour,
being on the stage,
connecting with the fans.
Getting to kind of create
the vision and, you know,
create the show and watch it
come to life every night.
Man, it´s unreal.
-You have different acts
touring with you,
and some of them are I think
what you would consider
conventional country acts,
but you also have
some different genres.
Is it true that Nelly has been
on tour with you guys?
-We got Nelly out with us.
We got the Backstreet Boys.
-The Backstreet Boys?
That´s fantastic.
-Mixing some genres,
crossing some lines.
-And are there times where
you look out and you say,
"Oh, I think there are people
here that would not be here
if it wasn´t for
the Backstreet Boys or Nelly?"
-Uh...
You know what?
Yes and no.
I mean, our fan base is
pretty diverse, as well.
But it is cool. I mean it´s --
it´s wild to see country music
fans going nuts for two hours
before we hit the stage
for Nelly and Backstreet,
and it´s really a cool vibe.
-Now, were you guys
Backstreet Boys fans growing up?
-Dude, they were
my first concert.
Sixth grade, House of Blues,
Orlando, Florida.
I´ll never forget.
-That´s fantastic.
-Full circle.
-I would definitely bust on you
if Vanilla Ice
wasn´t my first concert.
-Yes!
[ Laughter ]
-That´s a good one.
-So who am I to judge?
-That´s a great one.
[ Laughter ]
Now he´s flipping houses on TV.
-Yeah, so he´s doing great.
-He´s killing it.
-Ice is doing great.
-You guys --
you did Wrigley Field.
How was that?
How was performing Wrigley Field
for a concert venue?
-That was a dream come true.
-Yes.
-I mean, absolutely amazing.
It sold out, so that alone was
amazing and then, I mean,
the fans in Chicago,
we love Chicago.
I mean, their energy is electric
and it was a special night.
-Were you drafted to play
in the majors?
-I wasn´t drafted, but I played
baseball all through college.
I played in
three different colleges.
Florida State for two years,
Daytona State College,
and then Belmont for my last
two years of eligibility.
So it was a dream at one point,
but music took over,
and pretty cool to play
our songs in a baseball stadium.
Wrigley, Fenway. Crazy.
-It´s, like, the one thing
that´s harder to do at Wrigley
than play baseball
is play a concert.
Like, you did the thing
that has actually had
the odds stacked against you
more than that.
-It´s crazy. Yeah.
-So congratulations on that.
-Thank you.
We´re super blessed.
-I want to ask about this.
Whose house has this --
This is a treehouse
that one of you has.
Is this yours?
-My wife and I have a cool
little spot out in the woods
outside of Nashville.
And we got Pete Nelson
from "Treehouse Masters"
build us a little tree house.
-There´s a guy --
There´s a place called
"Treehouse Masters"?
-On TV, yeah.
-Oh, wow!
-A TV show, yeah.
-It´s a TV -- Oh.
-Where have you been?
-Well, obviously you watch
a lot of real-estate shows.
You´re telling me about Vanilla
Ice and now the treehouse guy.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, I have a problem with
real estate.
-Yeah.
I like to just pour
my peach pecan whiskey
and just watch some houses.
-Check on some Trulia, man.
Just check on some Zillow.
-This is gorgeous. What do you
do in your treehouse?
-So, we have
a little recording studio.
-That´s fantastic.
-It´s a creative space
so we write songs,
recorded a lot of vocals for our
"Dig Your Roots," last album.
Just a cool space. Yeah.
-I would say
this looks like a really --
I mean, it does look like a
place I would want to hang out.
-The fact that it´s like
15 minutes from downtown,
we can just jump over and kind
of get away out in the woods.
-That really speaks to what
a great place Nashville is,
that this is 15 minutes
from downtown
because 15 minutes from here
does not look like this.
-Not quite. Not quite, no.
[ Laughter ]
-You have to go a lot farther
from New York.
You can find apartments that are
as big as this treehouse.
-We´re thinking about building
one in Central Park, actually.
-[ Laughs ] Great, yeah.
-Still working on that permit.
-There probably are some weird
treehouses in Central Park
that the police have just
decided to let be.
[ Laughter ]
Now, you´re -- you´re
about to have a baby?
-Yes, we are. Yes, we are, yeah.
-That´s fantastic.
Congratulations.
-Thank you very much.
December 20th.
-December 20th. Whoo!
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So you -- you know what you´re
having but you got it wrong?
-We had it wrong. We did.
-Okay.
-Apparently, that is possible.
-Yeah.
-So, we had -- the blood test
was actually incorrect.
We went and got the ultrasound
done, like, the big ultrasound
at, like, five months
or whatever.
So for two and a half months
we thought we were having a boy.
-Yeah.
-And we were excited.
And then gears kind of shifted
for about a day and a half,
and it was a new surprise.
But it was something that
we´re both really excited about.
I think
it´s going to be amazing.
-It´s great.
Having just gone through it,
it is one of those things
when you find out the sex.
You think, you know --
you realize
they´re each super exciting.
-For sure.
-There´s no outside output --
-In different ways,
though, you know?
You kind of got to definitely
shift gears.
But give me some --
You got any fatherly advice?
-I mean, the only thing I´ll say
is for the first year
just never complain about
anything you have to do.
[ Laughter ]
-Own it.
-It´s, like, no matter --
if there´s a where you´re like,
"This is my third diaper
in a row," just eat that.
Like, just don´t --
-Literally.
-Because they really,
like, it --
I feel like it´s probably,
like 20, 25 years
before you can even
begin to catch up
as far as how much
the mother has to do.
-I understand.
-Yeah.
-Props to them, I will say that.
-Absolutely.
Well, thanks, guys,
for being here.
I can´t wait to hear the song,
and I really appreciate it.
Thanks for the whiskey.
Brian Kelley and Tyler Hubbard
of Florida Georgia Line!